[Musique]
les tests sanguins joue un rôle
important dans l'évaluation des tas de
santé d'un patient ils sont
particulièrement utiles pour assurer le
suivi des personnes souffrant
d'insuffisance cardiaque un chercheur
québécois a inventé une technologie qui
pourrait permettre aux malades de se
tester à la maison
dans une goutte de sang on peut lire
l'avenir on peut savoir si un patient
qui souffre d'insuffisance cardiaque
risque de se retrouver à l'urgence dans
les prochains jours
à l'université montréal le professeur
alexis vallée pire il développe des
tests pour que les patients puissent
décoder cette information dans le
confort de leur maison je sois le
parallèle avec les lire je pense le
glucomètre pili patients diabétiques
c'est tout si leur permet aux patients
de prendre en charge à quelques sa
condition au niveau des sciences
cardiaque du post
les suffisances cardiaque survient
lorsque le coeur n'est plus capable de
pomper assez de sang pour répondre aux
besoins des organes c'est l'une des
premières causes d'hospitalisation chez
les plus de 65 ans souvent les gens vont
rentrer à l'urgence ils vont soit
diagnostiquée suffisance cardiaque et
ces mêmes patients alors environ 40% de
chances de revenir en urgence dans les
six prochains mois
le médecin peut prescrire des
médicaments pour tenter de contrôler la
maladie le patient lui peut changer son
alimentation
mais la seule façon de savoir s'ils sont
sur la bonne voie c'est de faire une
prise de sang à l'hôpital ou dans une
clinique le patient doit se déplacer à
le résultat va prendre une coupe deux
jours avant d'arriver le résultat valait
ou médecins le métier de contact et le
patient donc toute la mécanique de
suivre un peu la santé du patient et et
lourdes qui a prend du temps vexé peu
réaliste pour un patient des sciences
cardiaque à la maison de se faire tester
par exemple à chaque semaine pourtant ça
serait seul besoin
le seul outil dont dispose le patient à
la maison ces deux personnes le malade
peut suivre son poids pour vérifier s'il
fait de la rétention d'eau qui est temps
on s'entend pour dire que la prise de
poids c'est pour ce qui est de plus
spécifique non plus pour évaluer une
condition leur surtout autant de haine
qui revient mais des sorcières
[Musique]
les tests maisons ont explosé ces
derniers temps avec l'arrivée des tests
rapides pour la coved le glucomètre
utilisés pour suivre le diabète est
connu lui depuis 40 ans dans les deux
cas ces tests mesurent un seul marqueur
avec le glucomètre par exemple on mesure
le glucose
poursuivre l'insuffisance cardiaque
c'est un petit peu compliqué faut suivre
la lecture de trois quatre marqueurs qui
c'est là que ça devient compliqué à la
maison
poursuivre l'insuffisance cardiaque un
test maison devrait mesurer à la fois le
potassium la créatinine est une molécule
appelée nt prot bnp
les tests sur lesquels travaillent
alexis ville est belle il fonctionne à
base d'adhésine synthétique comme l'adn
qu'on retrouve dans les organismes
vivants les prennent à dn qu'il fabrique
dans son laboratoire ont tendance à se
regrouper deux par deux pour former une
double hélice
pour faire le test le patient commence
par prélever une goutte de sang au bout
de son doigt
il ajoute une solution qui contient
plusieurs copies d'un brin adn la moitié
d'une double hélice
il dépense ensuite l'échantillon sur une
électrode d'or
à la surface de cette électrode se
trouve le prince adn complémentaires
l'autre moitié de la double hélice
si les deux brins arrive à se connecter
un courant électrique et générer plus
mesurée par un lecteur
la présence de marqueurs comme le
potassium ou la créatinine va soit
ralentir soit accéléré la formation de
la double hélice pour mesurer le
potassium par exemple alexis valley
bélisle conçu à brindas des haines qui a
tendance à 5 lutiner à cet élément en
présence de potassium donc le prince adm
se trouve figé salle elle ne sera plus
capable de venir liées sont bruns
complémentaire à la surface donc le
courant électrique va être beaucoup plus
beau autrement dit plus le courant
électrique est faible plus la
concentration de potassium dans le sang
est élevé
une fois le test compléter le médecin
reçoit les résultats par voie
électronique en cas d'inquiétudes il
peut voir son patient ou injustes et la
médication
pour commercialiser son invention
alexis va libellée à lancer une
entreprise anna sens avec trois
collaborateurs
il doit maintenant apprendre à parler le
langage des investisseurs soit en tant
que chercheur on dit tout savoir
améliorer la vie du patient mais pour
les investir c'est un autre langage sait
plus comment faire de l'argent avec ça
les investisseurs connaissent peu la
haute technologie et hamas ans n'a pas
encore de prototype fonctionnel et
complet faute d'argent
le monde dit oui mais terra nostra neuf
communes différentes terrasses elise est
de trop nous avait créé une entreprise
qui promettait de révolutionner les
tests sanguins
tehran aussi l'un des plus grands
scandales de l'histoire de silicon
valley l'entreprise promettait de
réaliser des centaines de tests médicaux
à partir d'une goutte de sang mais le
projet n'était qu'un écran de fumée et
la fraude englouti des centaines de
millions de dollars je dirais qu'au
début le fait que terrano ce que lever
10 milliards de dollars puis que
finalement c'est une fraude pique nos
masses d'argent a été perdue c'est sûr
que pour les maisons c'est quelque chose
de très qui sent beaucoup risqué
contrairement à terra noces la
technologie danas ans est basé sur une
science rigoureuse publiés dans les
revues scientifiques et plus
prestigieuses
alexis vallée b lille souhaite mettre
son test dans les mains des patients
d'ici trois ans
il espère révolutionner la vie des
malades avec une invention bien de chez
nous soit en tant que chercheur
c'est pas ta dumas qui monte de l'argent
mais de savoir que notre recherche pour
finalement créer des compagnies qui
elles vont faire rouler l'économie crée
de l'emploi tout ça c'est très
valorisant
[Musique]